this is artemis launch control at t
minus four hours and 45 minutes and
counting the rocket was primed the
countdown underway but as feeling of the
giant rockets began it became clear that
in that famous phrase
we have a problem the launch team has a
recommendation of no go for launch to
the nasa test director and launch
director a leak on the link pumping
liquid hydrogen into the tanks was found
engineers ran through the plans to fix
it launch director charlie blackwell
thompson just called
a scrub
but in the end had to admit defeat the
launch scrubbed for saturday we do not
launch until
we think it's right
and these
teams have
labored over that
and that is the conclusion that they
came to
so i look at this as a part of our space
program
of which safety
is the top of the list it's the second
time in a week the much delayed artemis
project had to be stopped short of
launch on monday it was an issue traced
back to a faulty gauge launch period 25
is uh definitely off the table we won't
be launching uh you know this period
ends on tuesday will not be launching
in this launch period
launch period 26 and 27
will really depend on the options that
the team comes back with likely on
monday
or early tuesday morning
thousands had gathered in the parks and
on beaches across florida's space coast
hoping to see a lunar launch
only to leave disappointed we brought
friends with us and it's our anniversary
and our friend's son's birthday hoping
the big candle would go off but it
didn't unless you've ever seen a rocket
go up there's nothing like it's heart
pounding i mean it shakes your whole
body and it's it's just something to see
artemis has been plagued with delays
with overruns and with a soaring budget
but nasa believes that even a short
delay is worth it for a mission that
will stretch over years
and stretch the frontiers of space
alan fisher al jazeera cape canaveral
florida